what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here john how's it
going john is good today awesome good to
hear that ladies and gentlemen we are
back after you know getting the vid
diesel john first correct second recoup
comic con a lot of marvel things to talk
about a lot of announcements and stuff
now we're catching up with everything we
got to catch up on brooklyn nine-nine
season three episode 16. leave a like
doesn't take a lot of work on your end
please go ahead and do it it's not that
difficult also subscribe and click the
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction for brooklyn nine-nine
is up here on the chanel full length
reaction watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code meaning your own copy
over for our sexy super rejects reverse
that uh patreon yep cover a bunch of
shows over there exclusively reaction
highlights and watchalongs included
lastly thanks to the prepper team
probably to set this down let's get to
it
[Music]
hey gina we got an anonymous gift basket
yeah it's full of treats it's got meats
cheeses candies all the food groups the
cheese is amazing did none of you
detectives think this might be a gift
for captain holt from someone
in france uh-oh husband
no way this is a nice present from an
unknown appreciative citizen that wanted
us to munch
what's this then
dear captain raymond holt thinking of
you best dr kevin kosner phd
i ate the chocolate covered strawberry
that's the most intimate snack of them
all yep we can fix this
check it out sir a lovely gift basket
that kevin sent you all the way from
paris straight from paris
[Laughter]
scissors
rubber bands
that man really knows me
[Laughter]
that's sweet i wonder what would have
happened if he got the cheeses and
chocolate
i feel like there's more bass i know
right it doesn't sound like they really
beefed up the low end
very high profile celebrity was robbed
in our precinct what celebrity sir this
is a sensitive matter and i can only
disclose details to the lead detective
on the case sergeant let me know who's
available asap yes sir put pearls on it
you know that i'm your guy for this you
can't give a celebrity case to amy the
last movie she saw was a documentary
about spelling bees
wrong it was about the font helvetica
and it played like an action thriller
[Laughter]
just work the case i assigned you can i
just give my case to hitchcock and
scully they do paperwork and they're
good at it they don't go out in the
field
boyle
you take the celebrity case what i'm
giving my drug bust to hitchcock and
scully it's time to get these mice out
of their heist wow that was lame life is
meaningless we're all gonna die mouse is
out of their houses yes i am the
greatest every breath is a gift sorry
about the roller coaster i'm just happy
i'm tall enough to ride
[Laughter]
it's like all of our conversations we
each agree to face one of our fears
today that sounds terrible but
i'm in
fine we're doing my thing okay
makes sense so look a big important drug
case came across my desk and i need your
help only problem is sarge doesn't think
you can handle it he's right
who fell asleep under their desks and
caught the janitor stealing evidence we
did and who sued the department and got
triple ply toilet paper in every
precinct we did that's a service
our victim
is john
william
weiss lebron remind me who that is again
you're kidding he's a world-renowned
oboist first chair with the new york
symphony orchestra oh god
huge fans of white shabron's work we are
what the internet sometimes refers to as
why should brawn fans
don't worry sir i can handle this so you
do think it smacks of preferential
treatment i don't know what you want me
to say okay you've convinced me i'll
work the kids with you
it's gonna be fun holt's celebrity was
just some lame oboist meanwhile we just
linked your little dump pot bust to a
major narcotics ring this might be the
biggest drug case the nine-ninth had in
years
oh no
i may have given that very huge drug
case to hitchcock and scully what in my
defense
i was pretty sure you were never gonna
find
i out if they mess up this case jake
it's on you they're detectives they've
been on the force for 500 years they
know what they're doing the only item on
scully's calendar for the entire year is
eat peanut butter yeah we got to find
them
residual cushion fart is about a six out
of ten he's been gone an hour maybe two
but where hot dogs they went for hot
dogs how do you know there's a water
stain on the ceiling in the shape of a
bun
let's go
[Laughter]
i just thought
you know the two of you might be better
off
mousing around the old house oh i get it
just because i got my fingers stuck in a
glue trap once i'm a mouse
i got the cheese out by the way oh my
god look man
i'm going undercover as text dallas
billionaire oil man from dallas texas
with ties to the cowboy mafia
in 20 minutes he's going in totally
alone unarmed without a cell phone to
meet with one of their guys to set up a
buy so how do you like our plan now it's
a disaster it's gonna go great come on
in i'll show you the back room where
they broke in you're an incredibly
gracious host mr white shabron wow that
pronunciation is flawless
[Laughter]
this is a pretty modest apartment uh how
did you afford a 40 000 oboe in the
first place i admit that there's not as
much money in classical music as their
ones which is the real crime here
[Laughter]
you just insulted our celebrity victim
to his face you keep saying celebrity
but he's drying his socks on a george
foreman grill this is john william
the silver spit prince
you're too close to this okay
oh no we are women standing up and
supporting each other and becoming
you fear listening to amy inspire us be
back in a half hour ames
come back i can't do that no you're the
best
that i sound like a natural laugh
the first 10 minutes were really
terrible
the diaper did not fit it was for a baby
i think the lesson here is that as women
we no
you close that truck again i will kill
you you hear me i will kill you
i'm beginning to think you were lying to
us i was lying i already admitted that
well if anything happens it's because of
you
right monk right hitchcock dies it's
cause of pinto
[Music]
chickpea
[Music]
chickpea
chickpea you couldn't just do the case i
assigned you hitchcock's life is in
danger he has a wife man but that coat
so what's the plan we stick with
operation beans you knock on the front
door i say i'm text dallas you're my
buddy alamo and you're black fred black
friend why black friend there's no other
friend yeah but they don't know that
eldy you stay here and call for backup
in case we need it oh no way that's my
partner in there i'm going in also i
can't call for help i don't have any
quarters
i was in the area and the captain is a
fan so i came by to give him a little
gift as a thank you it's a signed copy
of his book of mouth exercises read it
and weep read with two e's
it's my favorite joke of all time
[Laughter]
john you're under arrest what he stays
the robbery for the insurance money
because he's broke because obois are not
celebrities i found the oboe for sale
online we traced the ip address back to
mr weissel braun's computer
oh john
[Music]
[Laughter]
no you go first then i lower scully and
you
you get the catcher
great i love that plan got all three of
them with the coats man
look what i found french fries what no
it's a hitchcock where would i have
found french fries in a weed farm
it's a weed farm then
yeah gotta be everywhere
to conquer my fear of businessmen i must
walk among them i will shake their
clammy hands a suit
[Laughter]
also we all need to go in on those
flowers for beth
wednesdays
who are you again gina from sales i have
the plant on my desk oh yeah
you want to sit with us
we'll all be dead so soon
i ask only one time
who do you work for dea
fbi police i'm in the cowboy mafia i
work for the dallas buyers club
let me introduce myself my name is alamo
this here's tex and this is bread just
fruit and we are
the dallas buyers club
jesus
i'm just chagrined
deeply chagrined this is just like when
i found out robert frost was from
california
or when i saw mario batali with his hair
down
[Laughter]
for my plan to work he's got to be
basting in sweat hitchcock you once told
me you could roll that chair anywhere
think you could take it up those stairs
i once rode a chair home and a blizzard
oh yeah
i can go upstairs
oh christ my man's having a heart attack
help
hitchcock now
grab his gun
scully
black fred think quick no ow that was a
gun man scully grab that dude's knife
and cut us loose we're gonna get the
rest of these guys it's time for
operation beans phase two
the refrying
stop me stop me do it just do it
i'm psyching myself up
don't look at them look at me do your
job drain me
also i was worried they might want to go
out in the field more and i need
something to keep them at their desks
you really think that that is gonna keep
them out there and they're both asleep
already and the city safer for it
magnificent oafs you deserve it
fremulon
well all righty we did it all righty way
to go hitchcock and scully
that
it's not it's nice to see them actually
get an episode where they get a shine in
the field and do something of
significance and then
watching as the writing figures out how
their
quirky idiosyncrasies come in handy
and it did paid off in the end 100
lean bean killing machine there you go
we got there you guys did it
you guys did it
that was delightful
but my favorite stuff has got to be holt
oh totally um because we've all seen
that kind of comedy stick before of
obsessing over the celebrity but
you know seeing uh holt's childish
behavior come out and
getting clouded
by his own affinity for this man
was just a delight
it's just something like
this is this was an example of andre
brauer truly elevating material because
in all honesty i didn't think the
writing of this particular episode was
the best that brooklyn nine-nine is like
some of it was actually falling a little
bit more flat for me than usual or or i
could just kind of feel
the writing a little bit more like it
just didn't like some of the life was
sort of missing for me in it it's not
bad it's not a bad app i don't want to
know it sounds like i'm really putting
this episode down it wasn't bad
like in terms of the writing it's
usually a little bit higher caliber for
me and i did feel that what andre brower
was bringing to the role in and of
itself like the way he chose to deliver
certain lines just really elevated a lot
of like a lot of that comedy just
wouldn't work if it wasn't for his very
very specific delivery granted i know
the writers right tending to the voices
of actors when it comes to these comedy
shows i still feel like you probably
brought something a lot more extra than
they themselves probably anticipated
that's just my hunch yeah john i i would
have to agree this episode sang in
everyone's performing
of the episode especially i mean
obviously like you said it's nice to get
a little more focus on hitchcock and
scully i feel like part of me has
is kind of surprised that it took this
long to do an episode like this but i
appreciated where they took that and
then seeing like amy and rosa and
gina all getting out of their comfort
zones and whatnot i thought the
business suit thing was the funniest of
all three of those gags but i i liked
them being all together and trying to
you know get a leg up for women in the
precinct
and
uh yeah you know don't don't meet your
heroes it was nice to see charles put in
a position and sometimes he is in this
position where like without jake
you know he's he's really kind of like
status one in that story and so it's
neat to see him
occupy that while holt is yeah fanboying
out and boyle's just doing all the work
in the background
it's good it was everyone was sort of
like called to be put against
type or against comfort zone in this
episode so yeah while it wasn't like the
most uh catch you by surprise or like
inspired joke writing necessarily i
appreciated just the
like general sort of fish out of
water-ness that comes of yeah pushing
every character out of their status quo
yeah he actually made me appreciate the
episode a little bit more by pointing
that out because everyone was pretty
like there was a scenario here where
jake would get a sign with a celebrity
and then you know boyle would be the
straight man while jake's freaking out
or vice versa between jake and boyle
but yeah boyle wasn't really
like set up for the comedy this time it
was it was holt who was getting the the
childish
behavior uh but that stuff was really
funny and yeah like stuff with the women
i'm like that's a really great setup
that's a really great gag bit that they
could do
uh but for some reason it wasn't really
hitting like there were parts of it that
were definitely really funny that i'm
sure are featured in the reaction
highlights uh you know but there's a lot
of jokes that just weren't quite
i guess it was like it was going down
with what the setup of the gags were
it was going down them exactly
the first thought you would have when
doing the comedy bits yeah it didn't
actually there were no surprises to
really be had with that
and and i think that's why it wasn't
really
quite hitting
the way it could have hit so well and
that's like the the sea story almost and
because it does divide up into like
thirds
it does sort of feel a little more
disjointed from the rest of the episode
because yeah on the terry and boyle
story like that's very unified the uh
hult and jake story and with hitchcock
and scully is very unified and then with
them like you get the point
uh but i almost feel like if that had
been like the a story of an episode and
then other things had gone to like you
know contrast with that
uh
which is like a small nuance of a tweak
but yeah like
cutting back to it was always fun and
amusing but it was the one that felt
like the least
unified or like i got the full view of
it you know it sort of felt like okay we
gotta cut back and now okay amy's gonna
do her bit and we're gonna come back and
jean is gonna do her bit
and i guess that's what you do with that
but yeah
yeah but the bits were like pretty
obvious yeah yeah that's that's what you
would write
yeah it's about
straightforward as it goes
you know um but still it was still
always enjoyable from beginning to end
and you know there's some really good
laughs to be had here
so
yeah i mean what more can you say it's a
20 minute comedy episode and it was
funny just funny stuff
it wasn't about chuckles and characters
or anything like that but made hitchcock
and scully feel more essential to the
team and
you know i don't know it's like i also
feel like hitchcock and scully are have
demonstrated before they actually are
really capable and i and i feel like
that this episode worked with their you
know like it was jake figuring out you
know their their their lack their their
um
you know their weaknesses and stuff and
then using that for strength in
situations working with it like being a
good team leader about the situation to
pull themselves out of the situation i
would have i still found myself craving
like i wanted to see a little bit though
of like them truly taking charge yeah
like oh you guys are actually there's i
wanted a little something of that juice
just to feel that jake doesn't
completely rewrite operation beans and
they yeah have some kind of author like
it does feel like jake kind of saves the
day by delegating yeah as if they had
figured it out and they had taken the
lead or if their uh you know ruse had
maybe worked a little better or
something like that like on the one hand
it's okay
on the one hand i'm okay with the choice
of like the drug dealers just never ever
bought them but part of me was like i
don't know it could be kind of fun to
see if the drug deer is actually dead by
yeah or something like that yeah and
maybe the plan is actually sort of
working but then it's good that jake and
terry are there because such and such
goes wrong or whatever like yeah i can
imagine other drafts of this episode in
a few different directions but my yeah i
think the writing of the the celebrity
one was the most surprising because they
are setting up for like some big
celebrity and you feel like the setup of
it seemed like okay you know boyle's
gonna get a sign jake's gonna secretly
work it and he's going to be geeking out
over whoever the hell the celebrity is
and then the way he uh you know um andre
brower slowly inched his way to becoming
primary detective because he was just
trying to become the because he was just
like too big of a fan
was was the most surprising of the
writing because that's the whole point
of comedy right to work is you know set
up and then subvert expectations like
maybe not fully but sort of you know
like that and i think that's when it
would really shine this episode um and
then a couple of jokes here or there
when it came to the other ones but yeah
we're being too critical over a comedy
show it's comedy just supposed to laugh
and we laughed we laughed and did the
bad job it's supposed to do so we did it
but sometimes you gotta say some [ __ ]
you know you gotta say some stuff yeah
you can't just praise at the altar of
the show you gotta be an engaged viewer
what if we like every episode it doesn't
feel exciting you know you gotta you
gotta sometimes give some criticisms
just to just to make it feel like oh we
don't just say yes to everything yeah
it's the suspense of the viewing
experience will they like this episode
this week will they like it next who
knows
that's what you gotta do provide it
provide
provide engagement that way yeah
so next episode predicts at the
beginning whether you think we'll like
it or not watch john's gonna kill it
with this patron
all right john kill the comedy oh do it
shout out whoever you want to shout out
hey
everett baker this is gonna be so funny
getting ready guys
every baker your name's got bacon and i
bet you like to get baked every baker i
bet you're like a slasher just wait
don't worry it's gonna be really funny
you love to bake cookies that you eat
after you've done getting baked so yeah
you got like baked goods on yourself and
then oh hey you can dance the baked
potato while you're doing it you know
you put on a record or something like
that and you wiggle your bum around like
uh it's getting like a real
baked potato dancing guy and then you
still just
get ready though because now we're
breaking into acting
are like undercover
and uh your your your story man will be
so rocky
i don't know what you're talking about
i'm getting the best parts right now
dude because everett knows all right
even if you don't get it everett totally
gets it right now he's at home being
like maybe don't just tend to one person
you know tend to
uh yeah well now we're gonna switch it
up back to is all about uh pixels the
movie with adam sandler which i assume
is your favorite motion picture we are
not dying we're getting to the best part
i told you just stop interrupting me
sorry please with your commentary and
your criticisms about how i should be
facing my fears of just really getting
to know everett pixel my baker instead
of hiding behind all these jokes because
really to me you're the celebrity
everett all right i'm just nervous
i don't wanna mess this up you know what
i'm saying each one of these i come into
i'm like i gotta go under i gotta create
a whole persona so as to come to you
with the uh most rich intent enthusiasm
and emotional ferv
and resilience i'm sorry it's okay baby
cakes don't even sweat don't worry don't
you cry cause me and everett we got we
got a thing going and and you know
you know man you're my sweet hot dog
with chocolate sauce on top
that could have been a lot better
[Music]
you